When Abodh Aras walks on the streets of Mumbai,
the city’s stray dogs unfailingly greet
him with a strong sense of recognition - many
times, to the surprise of passers-by.
When I was a kid, I used to see dogs being
taken away, dogs in our neighborhood, dogs
that we knew as Tommy or Blacky, and the municipality
used to take them away and kill them.
We realized that why should this be done when
there are alternatives.
For 22 years, Aras and his NGO, the Welfare
of Stray dogs have been working towards the
alternative.
Every Sunday, one of the many routines they
follow religiously, is to provide first aid
to about 20 dogs in the Fort area of south
Mumbai.
Earlier the municipal corporation used to
kill them because they thought it was the
only way it could bring down rabies or the
stray dog population.
For me, this 22 year old journey is a long-term
relationship.
And every time a dog passes away, a part of
me dies.
Stray dogs in Mumbai, who typically belong
to the indigenous Pariah breed, have had a
rough history.
They were considered a nuisance, and a threat
- because they are potential carriers of the
rabies virus.
In the early 90s, it was organizations like
Aras’ that fought hard for their right to
be treated humanely.
The way it used to work was - dogs used to
be kept for 3 days by the municipal corporation
in a dog pound, and if nobody claimed them,
the used to electrocute them.
We convinced the municipal corporation with
figures of rabies deaths have not gone down,
the street dog population has not gone down
- that let us try an alternative which was
a scientific humane method of controlling
the dog population - which is what we call
an animal birth control program, or which
is what we call sterilization or spay-neuter.
It wasn’t until 2001, that a set of rules,
under the Prevention of Cruelty to Animals
act, made it mandatory for local governments
to sterilize stray dogs instead of killing
them.
But a lack of infrastructure and funds has
meant that it has fallen upon NGOs to control
and maintain the stray dog's population in
Mumbai.
Welfare of Stray Dogs now sterilizes and vaccinates
close to 300 dogs a month.
What this means is that there are fewer stray
dogs and fewer packs – and so they are healthier
and friendlier.
Yet, one of the biggest challenges for Aras
is to get people to see stray dogs in a different
light.
I think what we call stray dogs are actually
not stray per se.
The world health organization will call them
is 'free-roaming pets'.
They are pets of the underprivileged, the
policemen, the hawker, the person who lives
on the street.
So they are the ones who look after them,
give them names.
Uma Khan cares for 9 such free-roaming pets,
who live with her in a makeshift shelter on
one of the city’s streets.
She works as a housemaid, and makes just enough
to feed her family of 2, and her adopted dogs.
But it hasn’t been easy.
Like Uma, there are many others who are part
of a relentless but silent army of dog carers
in the city.
Every evening, Shilpa Bej cooks for 28 dogs
in her locality.
A local feeder she has employed then carries
the tightly packed lunch-boxes to the dogs
eagerly waiting for their day’s meal.
It is a big responsibility.
Of course, we knew about it, so
People’s perception around street dogs has
changed where earlier they used to just see
a street dog being taken away, sterilized
and put back.
Now they see people coming an vaccinating
them, they see our animal nurses coming and
treating them.
So they think that at least if these dogs
are not harmful, then they are not harmful
to us.
And they are not.
So they’ve realized that this is the best
way that street dogs and humans can live in
harmony.